see a blue showing up for to honor
Fallen Chicago police officer Ariana
Preston during her funeral the young
officer was killed in a robbery earlier
this month but members of the squad
don't think she and other fallen
officers should be honored Rashida Talib
and Corey Bush were the only two house
lawmakers to vote against honoring
police officers who were killed in the
line of duty and of course they blamed
the GOP as the reason why saying quote
it is a document intended to advance
Republicans a false narrative around
supporting law enforcement and Gaslight
the public about where they stand and
while the squad keeps disrespecting cops
they are needed more now than ever
before a woman who has brutally attacked
on a subway says that she wishes that
someone like Marie and Daniel Penny
would have been around to defend her
if I had somebody like Penny around
maybe things would have been different I
probably wouldn't have suffered so much
pain and suffering and these things that
I go through I have so much self less
confidence about myself every single day
you know that I wake up and I look at
the mirror and I replay this image of
what of what happened to me you know and
I would never want nobody to have to go
through that to feel that every day of
their life really ever you know Danny
there were 556 law enforcement officers
killed in 2022
um majority of Democrats Republicans
vote voted for this and yet you have
these two saying that they aren't
interested well I think it's good when
the squad does this then you at least
know where they stand okay so fine and
so don't come blaming us and all of a
sudden the White House saying it's the
Republicans who want to defund the
police that was a ridiculous point and
they had to walk that back anyway but I
do wonder what the squads ideal
long-term future is what would they have
preferred have happened uh in the subway
car that day what would they have
accepted what was allowable in their
minds at what point would they want
someone to step in maybe never I don't
know I actually I would love to hear
them explain to me what that was now you
can feel terrible for somebody like
Jordan Neely who had a terrible
upbringing lost his mother was homeless
was trying to make it as an impersonator
on a lot of drugs arrested 42 times you
can feel bad for him and you could say
that even that the system failed him but
at some point does the system have to
protect others isn't that what the
system of government is for and I wish
that they would have to explain that you
know Greg people like Corey Bush who
voted against this resolution don't want
that to happen to them which is why they
call for defunting the police and use
money to pay for private security so
it's fine when it happens to other
people on the subway but not to them
yeah I would be okay with it if they
hired security from the groups who hate
cops right don't use don't use retired
police officers or present-day police
officers I'd like to see how it works
out if criminals protect them and see
how far that gets them that female that
was on I can't remember her name so I
don't want to butcher it on on uh on
Laura's show
she's a victim because she doesn't have
the same security that the squad has
that's why the squad candy the squad
throws women under the bus every day
every day that they ignore women as
victims they're the worst misogynist on
the planet it's a consequence I think of
applying the political filter to things
that never used to be political and this
is what happened when the left in the
70s decided that everything personal is
now political and so things that we used
to battle together like crime went from
one side to two never was like that I
mean liberals conservatives Democrats
Republicans we all felt that like we
wanted Safe Streets we didn't want our
kids beaten up and we you know we didn't
want people but that has changed now
because there's one side that looks at
through this the ideology the ideology
of Oppression versus oppressed so the
the leftists now can't do the human
thing and support people who are trying
to help others because we feel the same
way you know it's the prisoner two ideas
thing again they can't be with the other
side because that's politically evil so
they side with criminals you know Jesse
we heard a lot during BLM um a lot about
defunding the police but also that
people in these communities wanted
police officers who looked like them who
were part of their community and here we
have officer Preston who was killed by
teenagers in her hometown and the squad
is behaving like this yeah they're going
to pay for this politically you know
when you have those really wild votes in
Congress like a Barbara Lee who will be
the only member to not vote for the
Afghanistan Invasion or someone like
remember Ron Paul used to be the one
sole vote against like the most popular
thing ever those are usually principled
votes that
you get a lot of heat for but I
understand those types of votes and
those are brave votes this is not a
brave vote this was one of those
political
things that McCarthy did to DARE the
squad to vote against it hey everybody
let's just give a nice salute to the
police
and they walked right into the Trap it's
not like this was going to fund or
defund the police there was no policy
here this is going to be used against
the Democrats so viciously in the
midterms they're going to say the squad
Democrats voted against
saying add a boy to Cops and they just
handed a huge political weapon to the
right and they just made Nancy and
Hakeem go oh my God are you kidding me
over here all you had to do was fall in
line and say I like cops too is it that
hard but they tried to make a stand like
it was on principle but it was on
politics and they blew it and it's
hypocritical as well Jessica
well we've been saying the squad but it
was half the squad I mean this isn't
even a unified front squat
they staunched the squad
stop the bleeding
um and I thought that that was telling
that AOC didn't vote with them Ayanna
Presley didn't vote with them Jamal
Bowman didn't vote for them these are
people usually pretty unified
um about an issue and I think that if
you are going to take a quote principled
stand which I'm sure that they think
that they did were owed a much more
thorough explanation as to why you
wouldn't stand up and salute this young
woman who seems like an incredible
person they blame Republicans well but
that's not a full explanation because
there are often I'll credit Dana for
this sometimes we'll be talking about a
bill and I'll say I can't understand how
Republicans voted against it and you are
detail-oriented you say well this is why
whether I agree with it or not there's
usually a decent reason that can be laid
out whether you agree with it or not it
doesn't seem to be the case here and
there were tons of Elections that went
on
yesterday and if you look at what
happened in Philadelphia there was a
Democratic primary yeah and the
candidate with the tough on crime
candidate who talked a lot like mayor
Adams have been talking who even said we
may need to bring back stop and frisk
was the one who routed Yeah the more
liberal candidate and I think that you
were going to continue to see this all
across the country we now have a
Democratic mayor of Jacksonville
also talking about how important it is
to make sure that people aren't robbed
aren't murdered aren't raped Etc and
that is going to be on the Forefront of
what goes on in 2024 and moving forward
yeah well cops are having a really hard
time recruiting this officer officer
Preston was only 24 years old
um so we'll see also she had just
finished her math degree and she
obviously she wasn't able to
attain the opportunity to go and get her
diploma and her mom did it for her yeah
the weekend terrible hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now